Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday.
Today's video is like A Song of Ice and Fire;
it comes to you in three parts, unless its
creator decides midway through to expand it
dramatically.
Along the way, I'm going to update you on
the Bank of Nerdfighteria, the unstoppable
force that is AFC Wimbledon, the immovable
object that is world suck, and a little something
I did 10 years ago.
Oh my god, I am so old.
But let's delay the midlife crisis portion
of the program, and start with part one: Batman.
So, pretty much everything I said about Batman
in my last video, Hank, was either wrong or
dramatically oversimplified.
And in the wake of that Hank, it occurred
to me that being wrong is one of the most
complicated pleasures I know of, because of
course, initially, I felt defensive, and then
very embarrassed.
But then I started to think about the fact
that the way I look at the world can still
be changed by the people I look at the world
with, which is exciting because it means I'm
not, like, finished.
And that's good news for an incredibly old
person.
Part two.
Why am I wearing a suit?
Oh, it must be time for the bank of Nerdfighteria's
semi-annual report!
Hank, the bank of Nerdfighteria is like Tyler
Oakley: it has two arms, the lending arm and
the giving arm.
Let's start with the lending arm.
Over at Kiva.org, Nerdfighters have now loaned
more than 4.5 million dollars to entrepreneurs
in the developing world.
That's amazing; we're one of the biggest groups
in Kiva's history, but the growth has been
slowing down a little bit in the last couple
month, so if you have 25 dollars or more that
you can loan to a developing world entrepreneur,
join the Kiva Nerdfighter group!
There's a link in the dooblydoo.
There's a 99% chance that you'll get payed
back which is like a negative 1% interest
rate savings account, which is basically the
same interest rate as they're offering in
banks.
Then there's part three: the giving arm.
So Hank, Nerfighteria has an actual, like,
federally sanctioned tax deductible called
the Foundation to Decrease World Suck.
It gathers money mostly around the Project
for Awesome and gives it all away to charities.
But this year, the Foundation to Decrease
World Suck has been unusually active outside
the P4A.
Like we raised over 300,000 dollars for Water.org's
work in Ethiopa and over 90,000 dollars for
sarcoma research during my silly World Cup
fundraiser.
And right now, partly thanks to Nerdfighter
projects like Minecrfteria, partly thanks
to the fact that more Vogbrothers income is
going into the Foundation, we have about 45,000
dollars in the bank.
That's a great start - going into the Project
for Awesome, we're in our best shape ever.
Part four: my suit isn't all business.
So Hank, I play FIFA as AFC Wimbeldon, and
then the ad revenue from Hankgames goes to
sponsor the actual AFC Wimbeldon.
They're this fourth tier English club formed
by its fans after their club was stolen from
them and moved to Milton Keynes.
And this year, our sponsorship has allowed
us to be on their shorts!
I know what you're wondering: if the shorts
are up here, what's down there?
That's none of your business!
Anyway Hank, two weeks ago, MY AFC Wimbeldon
beat Milton Keynes; in a thrilling foreign
four-nil victory, Bald John Green did the
mustache of joy!
And then last week, the ACTUAL AFC Wimbeldon
played the ACTUAL Milton Keynes AND THE BALL
COMES IN TO AKINFENWA!
AKINFENWA!
AKINFENWAAA!
And AFC Wimbeldon emerged victorious as the
crowd chanted "Who were you, who were you,
who were you when you were us."
Clearly Hank, having DFTBA on your shorts
leads to athletic success.
Wait a second, why am I number 37?
[Gasp] It's because I am 37 years old, oh
my god.
Which brings me nicely to part five.
So Hank, ten years ago today, I had just finished
the last edits on this little boarding school
novel I'd written.
My hope port was that it would sell enough
to make it to paperback.
It never crossed my mind that it would still
be in print after ten years.
And I certainly never imagined that there
would be this beautiful tenth anniversary
edition with a cover designed by Rodrigo Corral.
And a big Q&A and a fancy introduction and
a bunch of scenes from early drafts.
But that book has surprised me over and over
again in the last ten years.
I want to thank everybody who's read it so
generously and shared it.
Also if you want to get the tenth anniversary
edition, there is a link in the dooblydoo
to preorder it.
Part six: Hank, you know how long ten years
is?
It's the difference between second grade and
your senior year.
i don't want to panic, but Looking for Alaska
came out ten years ago, which means that I
am extremely very old.
I'm having a smidge of crisis about it, so
old Nerfighters if you have any advice, I
would appreciate it.
Part seven: Hank, I saw you on freaking TV!
I was watching the Walking Dead and then AHHH
IT'S HANK!
That advertisement was the scariest and most
exciting part of the whole hour, which is
really saying something.
So congratulations; it's fun to see you on
TV!
But all things being equal, Hank, and I know
you share this opinion, I'd rather see you
on YouTube.
I'll see you on Friday.